rabbit oh that is a pretty tight sword
oh oh do you get it you're gonna wish it
you're the only one Oh give me that [ __ ]
no bro I'm a yo dude I bet you're gonna
have to use it on something he knows
warm princess Wow don't let him go to
town let him go to town I'm just gonna
watch my two swords at me Idol oh is
that a nice guy that guy story the angle
it's Leo's eyesore guy's guy yeah let
them come in a little bit though I want
to like but they're they're running from
you oh good night good night sweet
prince yeah sup boys oh I'm Nancy gonna
kill the fair what I want to do like a
sweet jumpy move and I got over at
making you do a jump or does it already
jump for you like oh no no I can jump
down go hey am dunk on him jizz am up
tops all guys that hurt me real bad she
would it there's some guys up top the
toil I'm trying to need is an ego
Montoya you killed my father okay
there's a guy I'll get that guy for you
Ron he jumped away as in all seriousness
the sort of sweet but I kind of miss you
although you know what I'll do
understand so hard to get two guys first
where are the swarm princes oh good
princes are coming for the swords others
there's 10 for someone pick up I'll
cover to come on my legacy where's this
do you have the sword though you still
have it no it [ __ ] drop rid of a
breeze now it's mine oh alright oh there
are oh yeah oh where where right there
try to come from that wreck no no you
like to win you're gonna get killed
waters you said looks like there was
more let's say they're not glowing like
the other one listen man I'm quickly
quickly quickly I'm trying to we're
gonna revive you not pick up the sword
you might want to pick up the sword I
grabbed it Reverend right now but go go
go we get rid the boom shakalaka and did
nothing oh no hurry men I think you need
to use a sword on her Oh run
yeah no I can't pick them up you see
some type of toggle where I can pick it
up Chris oh [ __ ] oh I need help oh it's
a sword battle I think you need to use
the sword killer yes like I mean I am
using this way it takes quite a few
swords also his name is Prince so I
think you're angry if I don't hurt well
you know sometimes you just got to use a
machine gun yeah for sure an arnold
schwarzenegger just mashina okay oh no
I'm out of bullets this is dumb just
kidding oh no I got it I got him a girl
no scope there you go there's one do we
get the sword do get how come on the
prince had a sword just stroll the soil
oh oh there is a stone sword over here
oh it's because that's the one that you
died with right no it like respawns at
the spot where you initially pick it up
ever there's only one right there
someone's are way more powerful oh let
them down I just judge a shoe horn oh no
no no I'm the only one left regen it's
all on your shoulders Tay oh that's
great evade evade circles grave Oh get
it serpentine motions zigzag I'll get me
up I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying
joyful oh I picked up the relic instead
[ __ ] I got you and I died doing it
that's you uh why don't you want to Res
me yeah let me get rid of this sword
range cougar I'm on the other side you
Oh God okay well he's dead too yeah Shh
book it oh I read I read one no no no no
you can only take one hits yeah the
second hit is the kill shot all right um
you know racket moving here ok go for it
thanks sir he's gone oh god I can feel
oh my god that's warm grab the sword oh
my grad work oh you have it yeah but it
seems like it closed just hand them back
oh yeah you can actually use the sword
to know nervous it's gonna say dodge out
of there but the need is and gems
right now bring it on oh I could use my
super charged with the sword no
I jump over you wow he's really easily
like fool yeah yeah you jump over him he
doesn't even know they're mine cookies
here this don't stay in the same spot
just don't stay in the same after school
I could do that yeah but I'm really too
close to this mattress right whoa get me
out here oh he got oh nice colorful one
more we got her one more all right good
work get spread out we've got the sword
right now I got it
who humbly brawl come to me
oh jeez hey mr. Prince
no princess man who's lost some sort of
hierarchy you think maybe with each
other more than yeah right yes
everything killing is real blonde oh no
no no hey I'll Prince guys Oh fire print
oh I are friends learn to read I thought
you were there librarian I'm actually
rerio more libraries I don't worry don't
worry nice oh great terrible tamantha oh
it did not like that
I'm gonna stab me ok bad I did would you
die no I did not I survived take one hit
from them
he's going down oh yeah there you go
yeah yep okay nice good work see debt is
that it yeah tinkle oh that's sort of
seven hmm look for the perk right
slipper crates their grades